[Music]
get off me so how many were that before
me what that's kind of a sudden quick
why would you ask me that right when we
wake up do that please just answer the
question not doing anything you're just
being weird for asking me you know what
you're wrong fine what do you mean by
how many I mean how many have you loved
before me
love as oh my god get the [ __ ] out
behind okay I'll tell you about all of
them no I'm okay I'm gonna stop you
right here while I still love you so I'm
gonna just walk on you what when where
why who I loved was mr. Johnson just
don't interrupt my narrative I was a
senior in high school and I was so tired
of the boys my age I just wanted someone
who was mature and had a job goals wife
and kids it was really weird cuz he kept
telling me that I shouldn't tell anybody
but I wanted to tell the world you know
I even surprised them by showing up it
is not some time in sexy lingerie
funny though cuz when I came back he
didn't teach there anymore it was right
around the time when I changed my
relationship status on facebook
I probably shouldn't put his name on it
[Music]
what I love oh my god
and there was Terrell what I loved was
[Music]
next when I loved was my first
girlfriend in college school room what
woman's touches unique Oh impossible to
replicate by a man college was a time of
innocence discovery and venture we
shared these three elements together
things like our first kiss and our first
shower and oh my god and our well you
don't want to know
sesame tempers there were parts that you
didn't you haven't touched and trust me
even though we were just kids oh we knew
what we were doing
where I loved was this guy I met at a
New York pizza place it's my first time
having a New York slice it just it felt
so wrong but it was so bright this
Koreatown tattoo on his chest his skinny
little asian mustache you know it was
just so exciting because it was
forbidden cuz I was seeing someone else
at the time oh that was yesterday you
sure let me finish my story why I loved
was the guy I gave the biggest scare of
his life he was gonna leave me so I had
to make sure he was obligated to stay me
sadden him the most
wasn't the fact that I was pregnant but
that I ruined his chance to play ping
pong in the Korean Winter Olympics hold
up
you have a kid yeah but I lost custody
anyway having the kid isn't what freaks
him out the most it was the fact that he
was gonna be trapped with me forever but
for the first few years he knew that he
would not stay I mean I made him
understand that you can run but
could never really hide oh my god [ __ ]
are crazy you are the 63rd you are who I
love because you would do anything you
would get beat sexually assaulted robbed
just for me and you are what I love
because you you let's move on you are
when I love because you and you are
where I love because where I'm at with
you you are all that I mean you are why
I love because you are never gonna leave
me so I have to knock myself up you are
none of them what the [ __ ] does that
even mean
you are the 63rd you are the last resort
[Music]
so how many were there before me get the
[ __ ] out tonight I asked you to
[Music]